welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition in this episode
we're breaking down hereditary it's a
film that I've never actually covered
before in the channel but it's always
been one that I revisited due to all
other things later throughout it there's
an overall sense of dread and eeriness
to the entire work and the movie is
laced with hidden details that really
add to its creepiness throughout this
video we're going to be going through
some of the scariest things in the film
that you may have completely missed
whilst watching it there will be heavy
spoilers here so if you haven't had a
chance to see the movie yet and don't
want anything ruined then I highly
recommend that you turn off now
make sure you subscribe to this channel
for videos like this every day
and if you enjoy them please drop a
thumbs up without the way thank you for
crock - they could get a quick clicking
button now let's get into a breakdown of
hereditary okay so the film opens with
an obituary for Ellen Leigh there are
several details within this that hint at
certain aspects of the movie and on
repeat viewings it fills in more and
more of the gaps about the character not
only was Leigh the grandmother and
mother to the family that the film
focuses on we also learn throughout the
movie that she was the queen of the cult
of payment payment is one of the eight
kings of hell and when researching the
figure I learned that his powers
included the ability to create visions
acquire servants make spirits appear
reanimate the dead and grant flight
which are all things that we see happen
in the film before the events of the
movie we discovered that Lee had
attempted to offer up a son Charles as a
vessel for the demon we learned
Charles's name in the opening of
bitchery
and it becomes important later as it
plays into what's really going on with
one of the central characters Charles
committed suicide accusingly of trying
to put people in him and though this was
diagnosed as schizophrenia we know from
the events in the movie that this was in
the case because of his death Lee was
unable to give payment a vessel however
that didn't stop her from trying and she
waited until her daughter Annie had a
son named Peter at the time they weren't
really on speaking terms enough she was
unable to use him in a ritual to summon
the spirit yes later Annie and Lee
repaired their relationship and
had a daughter named Charlie she Ollie
was of course named after Charles and
from what we know the cult then set
their eyes on her this lip service paid
to Lee telling Annie that she wanted a
boy and this is exemplified in one of
the customized mats that Lee made for
the child which has her name is Charles
instead of Charlie the cult successfully
managed to put the spirit of payment
into the girl
however Peyman desired a male body and
thus he did not bestow upon them the
riches that they seeked though we see
the events involved from the perspective
of the family the film centers around
the cult transferring the spirit of
payment from Charlie into Peter all
whilst carrying out the rituals that
enable this possession to occur now from
the off there's a ton of foreshadowing
returning characters and just things in
general that don't pay off until the end
and he makes miniatures and we initially
start off with a slow pan across one
which then becomes the real world there
are a ton of theories that exist around
the symbolism of this but personally I
believe this almost dollhouse like a
snake shows that the characters don't
really have any agency or control over
the events that play out
they are like dolls unable to move and
divert from what's happening and this is
given Wade by the story of Hercules
which pops up in one of the many
classroom scenes we learn that the
character was a pawn in a hopeless
machine and that he didn't really have
any control over his fate dolls appeared
throughout the film and they too have a
lot of meaning to them the miniatures to
pick key moments in Annie's life and he
uses them as a sort of therapy to
understand the situation however they
could show that the cold were
controlling it all Charlie to makes her
own dolls and later in the film in
John's apartment we do see that she has
them to this layout of the candles and
dolls does slightly resemble the ending
shot for the film and it perhaps
suggests that everything is being
controlled by the cult from the shadows
we first meet Charlie sleeping in a
treehouse even though it's freezing and
this is where payment would later return
in the movie in order to complete his
rebirth it's a great way to
recontextualize our introduction to the
character in both the opening and ending
and adds a lot of subtext to the events
that are going on and the funeral we see
a creepy man smiling and he later
returns in the film standing in a
doorway we also see a strange symbol
that is worn by any animal
and this brings a lot of implications
with it the symbol appears throughout
the movie at several key points and it
belongs to Peyman one of the most
important instances in which it appears
is on the posts which Charlie gets
decapitated on it's painted and blood in
the Attic of the property it appears in
one of the cult members homes against
the wall on the cover of one of these
books and it actually ties back to
Peyman himself in one of the depictions
of the character that we see in the
literature on him we can see that there
are three heads hanging from his camel
these three heads would later be toned
down and repurposed to make the symbol
and the three heads of course represent
the three beheadings that we see
throughout the film these are required
to summon payment and they happen with
Lee's corpse Charlie and Annie at the
end of the movie now what the funeral
does is that it tells us that the cult
have always had their eyes on the family
and there's a really creepy moment that
you might have missed when first
watching the film before the family
returned home from the funeral we can
hear footsteps moving about the house
I'll play the clip of this twice now
with the volume increased but listen
closely for the sound of people walking
around the house before the family enter
did you hear that well we do learn later
in the movie that there had been cult
members which had drawn a triangle in
the house and transported Lee's body to
the Attic so it is likely that at least
one of these instances happened here and
he seems relieved by the passing of a
mother but she's haunted by an
apparition of her in the darkness and
from here she attends a grief meeting
it's here that she meets Joan who we
learned was second-in-command to Lee and
throughout the film we discover that
she's now the cult leader
there are several clues that something
is off with her throughout the movie and
at the meeting when the leader asks if
anyone would like to speak Joan
immediately looks to Annie
perhaps subliminally forcing her to talk
Joan slowly sparks of a friendship with
Annie and they bond over the grief Joan
tells Annie that she lost her son and
grandson and they perform a seance in
which she proves the latter's existence
through the use of his favorite
chalkboard
however there's actually a clue that
this is a lie and when Annie bumps into
her at a car park we can see in the back
of Joan's car that she's purchased a
chalkboard set which indicates that this
was all a ruse we also see at one point
that there are letters and Flyers piling
through the letterbox of the home and
then one for a seance is produced over
the top of them this was to call Annie
to attend it
but after she didn't show up Joan had to
intervene payments light draws
characters to certain things and
throughout the film it appears that
numerous times to lead them down a
certain Avenue this is never more
evident than when Annie is in her
workshop at the right hand side of the
screen we see the light appear and then
Annie seemingly knocks a paint pot over
which draws attention to Joan's number
however if you slow the scene down and
look very very closely
you will see that the paint pot actually
falls over on its own and that Annie
never actually touched it this was the
work of payment the light also appears
in Charlie's room and leads her outside
we see footprints in the dirt and also a
woman burning a fire she stopped by
Annie but it does show that the light
guides people to certain places payments
light can be seen in the classroom
before Peter sees a reflection of
himself smiling and a - can be seen
coming through the rafters when he
starts to choke I'll talk about this
smiling later and what it could
symbolize but for now we'll just focus
on the light
there is later a fade-in from a scene to
the miniature which shows Charlie's
death and at points a bowl does look
like the light suggesting that Peyman
was complicit in the beheading those are
the more subtle ones but it is littered
throughout the film
speaking of beheadings charlie cuts off
the head of a bird at one point and we
later see a drawing of it in which the
beak looks similar to scissors we also
see a model of houses stacked on top of
each other which suggests the idea of
homes and families built on those that
came before and how lee's goal was
always to connect herself to the demon
in order to obtain the power that it
would grant though we don't learn the
ins and outs of all of the rituals that
are needed to summon Peyman there are
actually a lot of clues going on in the
film that suggests the necessary steps
that one must take
firstly there is the three beheadings
that need to take place on top of this
we learn in the book of Peyman that the
target must be vulnerable and drugged
with a special herb that will open them
to possession this is called the dittany
of crete we later see that leaf ed
Charlie this is a baby in her bottle and
when Peter is smoking under the
bleachers it is likely that he too was
drugged with it we do see that his
friend on the left-hand side appears
towards the end of the film bowing
before payment so it is likely that it
was put into his system here when Annie
is drinking tea at Jones she pulls a
herb out of a mouth in disgust and this
is the same one that allows the spirits
to enter their lives
Peyman marks his prey by making their
own point in a specific position and we
see him carry this out on Peter this has
ties to the illustration of him in which
we can see that his staff has a bent
wrist and hand at the top it too returns
at the end of the movie and reminds us
of that head-banging scene after the
death of Charlie and he starts to lose a
grip and she turns to John who tells her
how to conduct a seance and he performs
this with a family and it opens them up
to Peyman who was able to tear them
apart and take over Peter the group
slowly start to close in on them and
throughout the film we can see several
of the cult members there is of course
the aforementioned one other funeral but
when Peter is smoking outside of his
window we can also see the breath of
someone standing there watching him a
woman can be seen waving to Charlie who
later appears in the Attic
and as things ramp up for the climax we
can slightly make out in the darkness
several figures standing around the
house when Annie fully loses it and is
taken over we can also see her hiding in
the top corner of Peters room it's
enough to give you a nightmares and it's
a scene that I've pointed out time and
time again to people because they
haven't actually know a state with the
attention mainly being focused on Peter
and the lighting of the movie obscuring
here for the climax of the film she
stalks him throughout the house and
hides in the corner of another room
before making her play and he chases
Peter but he manages to make it to the
Attic and she can be heard banging a
head against the door she somehow
manages to get in after this and beheads
herself and if you were wondering how
this was possible there's actually a
clue hidden in the darkness of the loft
that's because when Peter enters it we
can see cult members standing in the
shadows and they likely unlocked the
door and let her in peter scared for his
life runs out of the attic going
headfirst through the window and he dies
upon hitting the ground if you pay close
attention you can actually see the
shadow of his soul leaving his body
before payments light comes in and takes
over the ending theme itself has a mix
of bells and trumpets and in mythology
this is said to accompany payment when
he comes to earth he travels to the
treehouse where Charlie slept at the
beginning and finds that Li and Annie's
corpses have been reanimated and are now
bowing to the statue of him with the
bent wrist staff Jian gives him his
crown and explains to him what's going
on and she actually calls him Charlie
instead of Peter showing that this was
always his original identity the camera
pans out to an almost model-like
structure once more showing that he has
arrived we then cut two credits however
the creepy aesthetic isn't over yet and
we can see in the names that one letter
turns red and then drops down to the
next name symbolizing the hereditary
nature passing something on through our
genes now as for this smile earlier in
the movie do you believe that there was
a secret agenda by payment to separate
Peter from Annie we see his reflection
smoking in the classroom even though we
know that the character was not after
Charlie's death the relationship between
the two breaks down and any complaints
that Peter won't admit that he's guilty
and that he always has a stupid face on
his face I don't think that's the exact
line but you know anyway
it is possible that this was payment
doing this in order to drive them apart
and he was forcing Peters smile even
though the character didn't want to we
also see Annie sleepwalking throughout
the film and dreaming that she set Peter
on fire she also tries to pull his head
off at one point and this could be her
subconsciously trying to save a son from
being a vessel for the demon there's a
ton of things going on and no matter how
many times I watch the film I always
spot something new I'm glad that I
finally got around to covering this and
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on the film and if there's anything I
missed
come and below and let me know and if
you enjoy this video then please give it
a thumbs up make sure you check out a
breakdown of the insane details in mid
Samar which is going to be linked at the
end we go over the hidden faces
subliminal messages and more so it's
definitely worth checking out if you
want something else to watch you want to
support the channel from as little as 99
cents a month then please click the join
button below
we massively appreciate it and as a
thank you you get access to content
early if you want to come chat to us
after the show either follow us at
definition white tea or click the
discord link in the description below
those are the best ways to keep up to
date with heavy spoilers so hopefully
we'll see over there very soon this is a
channel for people who are mad into
movies so if that's the kind of thing
you like hit subscribe
huge thank you for taking the time to
watch this I've been definition you've
been the best now see you next time take
care peace
[Music]